Speed, strength, agility, and endurance are top-flight footballer needs...
...to react quickly, dominate opponents, and run fast,...
...all without tiring for 90 minutes.
Always quick-paced matches are played in increasingly tighter spaces.
Since the 1980s, the frequency of intense movements like sprinting...
...has doubled and the physique of footballers significantly increased.
Being tall and strong is an obvious advantage for a goalkeeper.
With an average size in European clubs around 1 meter 90,...
...they can cover the goal area more easily as well as intimidate opponents.
Defenders tend to be at least 1 meter 80.
Positioned in central defense, they need to be strong in the air...
...to win duels in their part of the pitch.
Midfielders are the only players whose average size is less than 1 meter 80.
Endurance and fast recovery, both essential,...
...these players cover the most ground per match: more than 11 kilometers.
Those positioned in the outside channels need to have the most stamina...
...so they can sprint up and down the wings.
Forwards like Lionel Messi are able to repeat physically demanding actions...
...and run fast with the ball at their feet.
Physically, players tend to have two basic body types:...
...small and fast to outrun and outwit defenders,...
...or tall and strong enough to impose themselves on opposition defenders.